last week i made clear to the
metropolitan police commissioner
the scale of the change i believe
is urgently required
to rebuild the trust and confidence of
londoners in the met
and to root out the racism
sexism
homophobia
bullying
discrimination and misogyny that still
exists
i am not satisfied with the
commissioner's response
on being informed of this
dame crescendo dick has offered her
resignation which i have accepted
it's clear
that the only way to start to deliver
the scale
of the change required
is to have new leadership right at the
top
of the metropolitan police
i'd like to thank dame president dick
for her 40 years of dedicated public
service with the vast majority spent at
the met
where she was the first woman to become
commissioner
in particular i commend her for the
recent work in helping us
to bring down violent crime in london
although of course
there is more to do
i want to put on record again
that there are thousands of incredibly
brave
and decent police officers at the met
who go above and beyond
every day to help keep us safe and we
owe them a huge debt of gratitude
i'll now work closely with the home
secretary on the appointment of a new
commissioner
so that we can move quickly to restore
trust in the capital's police service
while keeping london safe
what was the final straw for you was
there a specific issue or was it a
culmination of recent events
i was shocked when i read the irpc
report
into the actions the behavior the views
of 14 serving police officers
and the response from the commissioner
wasn't up to the scale of the change
required in the met police service
many people not just londoners have had
their faith in policing shaken by recent
events you've mentioned some of them
there some have actually been voicing
concerns for far longer how do you
intend to restore faith quickly
what we know
is the examples of the culture on
isolated and aren't historic there needs
to be a recognition
of the scale of the challenge before you
can have a solution
a prognosis
for the concerns that many many
londoners have that's why it's really
important we have the right leadership
at the top of the police service and
it's possible to recognize and pay
tribute to dedicated brilliant brave
police officers but also to say there
are big issues that need addressing and
just finally you said very clearly that
you didn't have faith in dame crested
addict's leadership given that she was
ultimately in charge of the
investigation into parties at downing
street involving the prime minister
boris johnson can the country still have
faith in that work it's very important
that i don't give a running commentary
on operational matters for obvious
reasons i'm a labor mayor
of london and there are investigations
into a conservative prime minister i'm
quite clear it's inappropriate for a
politician to be involved in operational
matters at the same time i recognize the
huge public interest
in allegations of the most senior people
in our country who are rule makers being
rule breakers because we're pleased by
consent
and intrinsic to policing by consent is
the public having confidence in our
police office and that's why this is so
important